remember when the media were saying that
the riots are actually peaceful protests
well we are way past that now here is
just a very quick timeline first they
said that the riots were peaceful you
remember they were standing there in
front of all the burning buildings and
they said actually no note ignore the
burning buildings really it's peaceful
then they admitted that the protests
weren't peaceful but they said that all
the violence was being committed by
white supremacists and we were looking
at the videos and we thought you know
man those are some pretty confused white
supremacists they do not look like the
typical Klansmen that we see in the
movies and I don't think there are that
many Klansmen in America so probably not
white supremacists then when it was
pointed out that the violent people in
the violent white people actually were
an Tifa they were radical leftists and
there weren't really any white
supremacists in sight then the left
wingers sort of denied that the ante fee
even existed then they kind of went a
little silent for a while now though now
we have reached a moment of honesty
where the left-wing media are admitting
that the the rioters are leftists the
rioters are not white supremacists they
are admitting that the protests have
turned violent
that the proto protests and the riots
are basically the same thing and they're
defending violent protests here is Chris
Cuomo brother of Governor Andrew Cuomo
head silly silly man on CNN defending
the violent protests now to many see the
protests as the problem no the problem
is what forced your fellow citizens to
take to the streets persistent and
poisonous inequities and injustice and
please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite and
peaceful show me where it says the
protests are supposed to be polite and
peaceful so he's not just saying that
they have to be put they don't have to
be polite he's also saying they don't
have to be peaceful let me show you
where it says that the First Amendment
to the US Constitution Congress shall
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or abridging the
freedom of speech or the press or the
right of the people to peaceably
assemble that's
it says it right there right in the
First Amendment the only plays in the
Constitution that talks about these
sorts of protests the liberal
establishment is now publicly supporting
political violence not just CNN this
goes all the way through academia this
goes all the way into our legal system
itself
welcome to mob rule I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
this goes way higher than Chris Cuomo
Chris Cuomo is a clown right Chris Cuomo
actually was said on tape just a few
weeks ago that he hates what he does
professionally if it's sort of
ridiculous so it's beyond him it goes
all the way up to the Attorney General
of Minnesota where this whole thing
started who himself is a radical leftist
defending political violence we'll get
to that one second first gotta get to
the the best answer may be that I've
seen in any of the YouTube comments
to our question yesterday what happened
to Pride Month the correct answer came
from Jim silly Michael Pride Month was
last year this year it's wrath month it
is definitely wrath month really makes
you long for those innocent days when we
were all just marching and celebrating
pride we have also got to thank our
friends over a Lifeloc speaking of
safety and security
you know I will admit even I have almost
been I actually have been duped one or
two times by internet scammers happens
to the best of us a hacker group called
shiny hunters claims to have breached 10
companies and is now selling their user
databases on a dark web marketplace for
illegal products the company is ranged
from an online dating app
yikes that's not good to a food delivery
service to online stores and newspapers
the listed databases hold 73 point two
million user records which are being
sold now for around 18,000 dollars very
important to take base of protective
measures against identity theft
LifeLock is the leader in identity theft
protection detects a wide range of
identity threats at like your social
security number for example going for
sale on the dark web no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses LifeLock
and see threats that you might miss on
your own join now save up to 25% off
your first year go to life law comm
slash Knolls that's LifeLock comm slash
normals canna wles to save 25% because
safety and security are rare things
these days keith Ellison is the radical
leftist in the Democratic Party who is
now the Attorney General of Minnesota he
was a congressman he tried to run the
DNC now he's the agian
soda you'll remember Minnesota is where
this whole thing started with the
killing of George Floyd keith Ellison
announced yesterday that he's going to
be upgrading the charges on the police
officer who was involved in the killing
he's going to upgrade them from third
degree murder to second degree murder
and there's a big problem and more
threats underway because of this
decision first today I filed an amended
complaint it charges the charges former
Minneapolis police officer Derek Chavan
with murder in the second degree or the
death of George Floyd I believe the
evidence available to us now supports
the stronger charge of second-degree
murder we've consulted with each other
and we agree oh does it now the the new
F what new evidence have we seen any new
evidence at all no the new evidence is
the riots going on around the country
that are helping this guy get cover to
increase the charge what's the charge
third-degree murder unintentional
second-degree murder intentional so if
you want to believe that this was
warranted you have to believe that this
cop in was intentionally murdering
George Floyd does anybody seriously
believe that no of course not one
because he why would this cop want to
bring down all this mayhem on his
himself obviously his life is ruined now
the race riots all over the country
everything is caught on video now so ya
had to know this this sort of thing
would be happening there's just no
evidence of it also if he had wanted to
intentionally kill George Floyd wouldn't
even T have done it more quickly than
within eight minutes
know what when you watch that video
very sad video you watch this man saying
I can't breathe please watch this man
dying you don't get the impression that
this cop is actively murdering him like
haha I'm gonna kill you now what would
the cop have to be thinking to do that
it wouldn't make sense now was the cop
acting I don't know recklessly was the
cop acting callously was the cub maybe
yeah I mean that that's for the court to
decide that's what people were looking
at on camera but now with a
second-degree charge he's more likely to
walk than if he had the third degree
charge was much easier to prove the
third degree charge much more difficult
to prove the sex
degree ellison goes on charging the
other cops who just happened to be
present at the arrest second today
arrest warrants were issued for former
Minneapolis police officers Jay a king
Thomas Lane and to town finally I'd like
to announce that today n Fe County
attorney Michael Freeman and I have
filed a complaint that charges police
officer King Lane and tau with aiding
and abetting murder in the second degree
a felony offense I strongly believe that
these developments are in the interest
of justice for mr. Floyd his family our
community and our state in the interest
of justice you believe that these other
cops who were present during the arrest
actually secretly had been colluding
with the officer Derek Chauvin to murder
this guy and they just decided to carry
out their murder they were going to do
it on camera and the most publicly way
possible that would make them completely
vulnerable and that's why they would be
charged long after this murder but not
long after the riot started to burn down
all the cities obviously this has
absolutely nothing to do with justice
but that's Keith Ellison's MO keith
Ellison is probably the most prominent
Democratic politician in America to
publicly endorse an Tifa antiva is a
terrorist organization and tief is a
group of radical leftists Communists and
anarchists that uses political violence
against civilians to achieve political
ends that is the definition of terrorism
keith Ellison has smiled with holding up
the antifa handbook the antifa handbook
written by an academic from Dartmouth
College Keith Ellison is not just posed
with the book he's posed with antifa
leaders keith Ellison is supporting not
justice but terrorism these guys Chris
Cuomo keith Ellison they think I think a
lot of leftists in this country think
that supporting terrorism I mean that
they wouldn't use that word but that's
what the definition is they think that
by supporting political violence that
makes them edgy they think that that
makes them revolutionaries they think
that makes them on the right side of
history the real effect of that the real
effect of the political violence they
support is to get people killed for
instance Italia Marie Kelly who's 22
years old a biracial girl speaking of
racial justice who was shot and killed
at a protest against police brutality by
a protester by the way outside of
Davenport Iowa at Walmart on Monday
here is Talia's sister describing the
scene so this is what Chris Cuomo and
Keith Ellison are supporting they
wouldn't put it in those words they
would probably say no I don't support
that well then what do you support
you're saying the protests don't have to
be peaceful respond was said that on
national television to all seven people
watching CNN keith Ellison smiling with
the anti-fascist political violence
handbook so what are you saying what
they're really saying I would imagine is
no no we don't want the civilians to be
killed we want the the unpeaceful
protests the violent protests to be
directed at cops so if they killed a cop
that's fine but you kill an innocent
civilian that that's not so fun well
this is what happens by the way even if
you even if you held that repulsive
premise this is what happens when you
allow mob rule to take over your cities
is they don't just aim perfectly at the
person that you've designated the enemy
everything goes haywire lots of
different people of lots of different
persuasions and categories get killed
buildings get burnt down law goes out
the window and law has gone out the
window
all the way up through our legal system
the lawlessness the unreason is not just
in law enforcement which by the way
we're seeing your Eric Garcetti mayor of
La just announced they want to cut over
100 million dollars from the LAPD budget
which is really which when they're
burning down cities and smashing
buildings and harming people that's what
you want you want to smash the the LAPD
budget but but it's not just in law
enforcement we're seeing science too so
actually there is some slightly good
news here you remember
hydroxychloroquine hydroxychloroquine
was that cure for corona virus or was a
treatment for corona virus that was
showing very promising results and then
there was a study that came out that
said it was really actually dangerous
and bad and that study came out after
Trump had publicly supported
hydroxychloroquine well now that Trump
has stopped publicly supporting
hydroxychloroquine hydroxychloroquine is
good again it's okay now that trumps not
talking about it actually it's healthy
for you The Lancet and another Medical
Journal the New England Journal of Saia
of Medicine rather issued an expression
of concern each of them four studies
that were coauthor by doctor sappin
Desai and and decides the one who raised
the alarm about hydroxychloroquine it's
hard to look at all of this
and not think it's just arbitrary right
it's hard to look at the charges in
Minnesota and say you're not basing this
on I mean there isn't any new evidence
you're just doing it because the mob
says so and you're moved by those
emotions hydroxychloroquine you went
when Trump was touting it you said it
was really bad then when Trump stopped
touting it you say it's really good
again beyond hydroxychloroquine look at
what the public health officials have
done the pennsylvania health secretary
dr. rachel levine i present this to you
first i will i will point out the
obvious which is that the health
secretary of pennsylvania is a man who
thinks he's a woman and he goes by
Rachel Levine that is obviously an
ironic circumstance that's not actually
the absurd aspect of the situation that
I want to draw your attention to I want
to draw your attention to what he is
saying that many other public health
officials are saying to which is they're
answering our question why is it that if
you walked outside even for a little bit
even just to go down the street and get
groceries three weeks ago you were
endangering public
and the deadly virus but today if you
gather in crowds of hundreds of
thousands you're not endangering Public
Health as long as you're riding and
protesting and hanging out with leftists
what why why is it that when you go to
church
it's endangering Public Health but when
you're protesting and smashing windows
and stealing Nikes you're not
endangering Public Health with a
completely straight face the answer well
so we have the governor has always said
that people have the right to to protest
and to demonstrate and the right of free
speech and so overall we want large
gatherings such as such as maybe a party
or or some type of concert or something
to be under two hundred and fifty people
but we are not restricting people's
right to protest there are also
obviously significant social issues you
know that our president that people feel
that they need to have a voice and so
the governor is always supportive of
that and in this participating in that
so let me distill that down for you if
the people are doing something that the
Democrats support it's fine and if the
people are doing something that the
Democrats don't support it's not fun so
that was the kind of long rambling
answer I also love now that the these
Democratic leaders are so in favor of
free expression that's not what I was
hearing from them a few weeks ago during
the anti lockdown protests during the
anti lockdown protests I heard this is
going to kill grandma this is going to
kill lots of people you've got to stay
home it's selfish it's a wrong version
of freedom but now that the that the
hundreds of thousands of people in all
sorts of municipalities are protesting
based on a lie right based on the lie
that there is this scourge this epidemic
of
of police officers killing innocent
black men around the country not
happening we went through it on the show
yesterday it simply is not taking place
even when you look last year at the
number of unarmed black men killed by
police officers and by the way unarmed
does not mean not dangerous but even the
number of unarmed
what's the number 9,000 no 900 no 90 no
the answer is nine nine and and many of
them many of them were virtually all of
them were posing a threat to the police
officer not saying that every death
isn't a tragedy every death is a tragedy
but that is not evidence of systemic
slaughter so going out and rioting and
killing people now killing killing more
people in the riots than were killed as
a matter of unarmed black men last year
by police doing that is perfectly
acceptable because because I because why
because the Pell Pennsylvania Health
Secretary said so he is not the only one
there is an open letter from over 1200
public health expert scientists saying
that yeah the other kinds of protests
that were conservative or bad but these
riots and protests are essential for
public health open letter advocating for
an anti-racist public health response to
demonstrations against systemic
injustice occurring during the Cova 19
pandemic at least the scientific experts
acknowledge it here they say on April
30th heavily armed heavily armed you
break and predominantly white protesters
well that's terrible it can't be why
people can't protest enter the State
Capitol building in Lansing Michigan
protesting stay at home orders and calls
for widespread public masking to prevent
the spread of kovat 19 infectious
disease physicians and public health
officials publicly condemned these
actions and privately mourned the
widening rift between leaders and
science and a subset of the communities
that they serve that's the first part
second part as of May 30th we're
witnessing continuing demonstrations in
response to ongoing pervasive and lethal
institutional racism set off by the
killings of George Floyd and Brianna
Taylor among many other black lives
taken by police many other we went
through the numbers just a few seconds
ago that not many other when we're
talking about this kind of specific
injustice a public health response to
these demonstrations is also warranted
but this message must be wholly
different from the response to white
protesters resisting stay-at-home
workers they're actually saying yeah I
know they look the same well they don't
look the same because the the anti
lockdown protesters were completely
peaceful and then went home and very
respectful and these rioters are killing
people in torching cities but you know
okay
they're both protesting but we need to
treat the really peaceable nice ones in
the American tradition horribly and we
need to treat the rioters wonderfully
that's what we're being told they say
white supremacy is a lethal public
health issue that predates and
contributes to Co vid 19 yeah is it now
I get it
nobody nobody here is defending white
supremacy I don't know any it's all
things like nobody nobody thinks that
black lives don't matter
nobody is defending white supremacy how
many how many white supremacists are
there not too many I know I don't think
but does anybody think it's a public
health issue I don't it can and even if
you thought it were a public health
issue do you think it contributes to Co
vid 19 you know we don't know a whole
lot about this virus some people say
it's transmitted by airs and people just
say it's transmitted about services no
one says it's transmitted by white
supremacy okay I haven't seen a
scientific paper on that they go on
protests against systemic racism which
fosters the disproportionate burden of
kovat 19 on black communities and also
perpetuates police violence must be
supported so according to public health
public health science can't debate
science you can't refute science
according to science we need to keep
rioting and torching cities signed by
1288 public health professionals with
this what this letter tells me is that I
should never again listen to public
health professionals because it's
obvious that they're charlatans it's
obvious that they have no idea what
they're talking about that anything and
it's obvious that they are using their
credential to weigh in on a subject that
has absolutely nothing to do with their
credential it doesn't really teach me
that because frankly I've known it for a
long time but it I think it shows the
rest of us that now public health
officials are now saying it is good to
riot and coronavirus won't spread if you
do
but if you protest for your civil
liberties that would be a very bad thing
and by the way they go further I kid you
not they go further in the New York
Times they say if the police break up
the riots then coronavirus will spread
not the hundreds of thousands of people
pouring in next to one another then it's
their immune somehow but when the cops
break it up because as the New York
Times says there are corrosive effects
of tear gas that could intensify the
corona virus pandemic - your guess so
you can't cops got to stay home the
scientists said so and the scientists
they know they know what they're talking
about because they have PhDs now by the
way that headline implies another lie
that we've been told we've been told
that when President Trump walked from
the Rose Garden you know through the
White House through Lafayette Park and
to that church the other day Saint
John's Church to hold up the Bible the
church that the peaceful protesters
tried to burn down the night before we
were told that the police used tear gas
to break up the protesters that's not
true the u.s. Park Police confirmed they
did not use tear gas they did use smoke
canisters they did use pepper balls but
no actual tear gas was used in the
Lafayette Square incident so since the
public health officials are so concerned
about tear gas then don't worry it's not
gonna spread the pandemic even Nancy
Pelosi admitted that my daughter
Alexandra filmmaker
journalist it was there that night and
she called me she said mom you wouldn't
even believe it these people were
demonstrating peacefully and all of a
sudden that this barrage of security
came through using clubs to beat people
on these explosive scat little bullets
that explode into stuff that burns your
eyes maybe they didn't have to guess I
don't know but they had the elements of
it well there you go there's the
admission okay maybe they didn't have
teargas I don't know but they had stuff
you know they had stuff and so I'm gonna
call it - your guess and then the public
health officials are gonna say that
teargas spreads coronavirus so they're
gonna let the the riders continue I also
love here that Nancy Pelosi is admitting
that her daughter was at one of these
riots
I guess it's part
you know waltz the governor of Minnesota
his daughter was giving these rioters
tips on where the National Guard was
going to be Chiara de Blasio Bill de
Blasio's 25 year old daughter she was
arrested in a group of people the group
of people is throwing objects at the
police during one of these peaceful
protests my conclusion the rioters are
immune only only churchgoers people with
jobs civil libertarians voters remember
you can't go ahead and vote that's why
we have to have national mailing votes
students diners and shoppers though
those are the people those are the seven
groups of people that can catch
coronavirus but looters and rioters and
anarchists and communists they they're
they're just immune they're not going to
catch it so it's okay
if they go out and protest the science
tells us that if you basically this is
the rule of them if you go out and build
or buy anything you're seriously at risk
you need to go back home but if you go
out to destroy or steal something you're
safe that's the science that's our
public health experts real collateral
damage here real collateral damage they
shut us down for two months people
couldn't go to funerals a teacher of
mine died during that time I certainly
would have gone to the funeral if I
could have if he had died during a
normal time I couldn't go to the funeral
and look he was just a teacher of mine
think about people who lost their
mothers and their fathers who couldn't
be with them at the very end who's who's
close family members had to die alone
and then who couldn't receive a proper
funeral because the public health
experts told us not to all those people
now are looking out and seeing hundreds
of thousands of looters and rioters
pouring out everywhere and the public
health experts are cheering it on if you
thought that our faith in her
institutions was fraying before this
whole thing oh boy Oh buddy it's gone
it's gone and yet people I think are
starting to miss it I think the very
people who were tearing it down are
starting to miss it now that it's
there was a scene this is my favorite
this is my favorite video that was going
around the internet yesterday a group of
young idiots the protestors very
peaceful were throwing objects at a car
as it was driving by because most people
just keep driving right not this guy
this guy he was not going to take a ding
on his car lying down so he's driving
the hit his car he stops then he starts
to back up and then you hear the
peaceful protestors say my my three
favorite words of this of this whole
incident call the police you see me
stops he's backing up oh I'll call the
police
multiple people please no you know those
brutal people who are slaughtering
innocent men and women all over this
country yeah call him call them now cuz
this guy is gonna be upset that I loose
it all and the guy runs out of his car
with something I don't even know what
this guy he's holding he chases the one
idiot away the guy goes running and then
he turns on the rest of the crowd by the
way this this is one man one older man
facing down like I don't know probably
eight or nine people and they all
scatter and run the minute that anybody
pushes back whatsoever they're gonna
hurl objects they're gonna break windows
they're gonna steal stuff they're gonna
burn down cities until they get any
pushback whatsoever but we haven't
gotten any pushback yet other than this
wild looking guy and so the chaos rages
on and the response from our elected
leaders is to defund the cops and our
response from our media establishment is
to encourage the protests if these
people in that video had one ounce of
self awareness they would hang it all up
the moment that they said call the
police and they would say they throw the
object the guy would turn around they'd
say oh no call the police oh oh right
okay now I understand never mind I'm
gonna go home everybody go home civil
order is a good thing but they're so
full of anger they're so full of fury
that they can't even realize that the
anger and hatred from these
riots is not even confined to people who
are currently alive the the anger and
hatred from these riots is now being
directed at people who died a hundred
years ago more than a hundred years ago
Ralph Northam you remember Ralph Northam
Ralph Northam and Virginia governor of
Virginia just announced the removal of
the very famous statue in Richmond of
General Robert Ely now it is not clear
as of yet whether governor Northam will
attend the removal ceremony wearing
blackface or whether he'll just be
wearing his usual hood it's we actually
never found out from that photo was he
the one in the blackface or was he the
one in the hood everyone got upset that
he was wearing blackface seems to me the
hood is actually a little bit more
offensive so we don't know which one he
is going to wear but we do know that
he's a very good person
you see he's very anti racist very just
because he's gonna take down a
historical statue and try to erase
American history and talk about how much
better he is then than a dead guy so
it's okay not no big deal
Keith Boykin CNN he's some guy I don't
know these guys who knows I've never
heard of this guy in my life but I don't
watch CNN but he is a CNN correspondent
he tweeted out quote robert e lee was a
racist traitor who fought against the
union he should never be celebrated on
public property anywhere in america
that's one take I think that's the take
that just about everybody has today
that's not Abraham Lincoln's take that's
not the take in the best traditions of
the United States that's not the take
that is going to allow us to continue as
a nation Abraham Lincoln said famously
in the second inaugural with malice
toward none with charity for all with
firmness in the right as God gives us to
see the right let us strive on to finish
the work we are in to bind up the
nation's wounds to care for him who
shall have borne the battle and for his
widow and his orphan to do all which may
achieve and cherish a just and lasting
peace among ourselves and with all
nations those are some of the most
famous words ever uttered by an America
and statesmen and the left in America
today has completely reversed it they
are promising us malice toward all and
charity for none they're doing that in
the Academy in the humanities they're
doing that in the sciences they're doing
that in the activist level peaceful
protests also known as riots they're
doing that at the attorney general's
office in Minnesota the legal Channel
they're doing that through the media
they're doing it every single place that
they have any influence the reason
Abraham Lincoln uttered those words is
because he knew that if we did not
follow that course of action the nation
would be ripped apart forever it would
never come back together that would be
the end of it there's no you can't hate
your fellow citizens and have a country
or you can't have a country for very
long you can't have malice for all of
your fellow citizens and charity for
none of them and have a country for very
long that's the choice that we have is
is anybody going to to take the Lincoln
approach I don't know or we still a
mature enough country to take that
Lincoln approach the jury is still out
let's see how long the riots burn we got
to get to the mailbag first though I've
got to thank you I've got to thank you
because I am so close I am so this close
to overtaking drew on the YouTube
subscriptions here so thank you for
subscribing to the Michael Nolt show
YouTube channel you probably watching
this on the daily why our YouTube
channel that's great
but head on over to the Michael Noel's
show YouTube channel and then I will
overtake drew who got like a week head
start on me and never told me but he was
trying to build up that channel so then
I look like you know nobody was watching
my show you can get special breakouts
over their interviews bonus segments a
lot of fun so please head on over
appreciate it also daily wire comm /
subscribe you get one tumbler right you
want that's good one time it was good -
tumblers much better that is what you
get if you right now subscribe to our
most exclusive membership tier all
access all access gives you our premier
level of membership you get a Q&A is
exclusive editorial articles from Ben
you get bonus hours of his show you get
an ad-free website experience it
couldn't possibly get any better daily
wired I come / subscribe join all-access
right now
15% off with coupon code knowles daily
wire.com / subscribe be right back
all right first question from Chris
hello Michael I'm seeing a lot of my
friends get caught up in the slacktivism
and virtue signaling as a result of
George Floyd of the George Floyd tragedy
these friends generally don't get caught
up in these hysterias this much they're
participating in blackout Tuesday and
Instagram and posting a lot of BLM
hashtags and whatnot
is it worth telling them that they are
just falling for the racism narrative
that the left wants them to believe or
is it just a waste of time
Thanks love the show it's not even just
the racism narrative if it were it'd be
easy to tell them that they're crazy
it's a religious narrative this is a
religious worldview it has liturgies
we've seen all these kind of weird
secular religious rituals over the past
few days of people like white people
kneeling down bowing before black people
who are standing up or the white people
reciting this mantra I will not be
racist I will not be racist you saw all
those videos we showed yesterday so as
you might know if you've ever known
anyone who's been involved in a cult or
like a really kooky religion it's very
tough to shake them out of it you know
you got to proceed a little bit with
caution and that's how I would proceed
here I wouldn't shame people for what
they're doing many many many of my
friends posted that stupid black square
on Instagram cuz they just they just
thought okay whatever it's a thing maybe
they felt pressured to do it maybe they
just thought it didn't mean that much
that's fine I don't care
it's no big deal but maybe you can show
through your lead that actually the
premises here are not true
the effect of this message is very bad
and it's leading the cities burning down
and people dying and it's just a false
vision of the world that's how I would
do it I wouldn't go and just say you're
completely wrong because especially on a
matter that is actually religious like
this is they're not gonna respond well
from Mali all week I've been subjected
to posts and personal messages about
educating my children about racism and
their white privilege not because of any
action I've taken it seems completely
inspired by the assumed inevitable
racist beliefs me or my children will
fall into since I'm white as are my
children my question is how is that
different than me sending out messages
to liberal or african-american friends
saying may I suggest a few books that
help teach your kid how not to break a
store window and steal Gucci bags Thanks
that is a very good comparison because
both of those things are equally
offensive right if you sent to your lip
to your leftist friends and your black
friends by virtue of their ideology and
their skin color a note that said hey
here's a way to educate yourself on how
not to steal Nikes that would be very
offensive they would be rightly offended
by that
likewise if they're if they're sending
you books and saying hey look I know
we're friends and everything but because
of your skin color you're evil so here's
a book on how not to be evil like me
because I'm a good person
and you're an evil person so here's
here's how not to be evil say okay
thanks that's great just throw in the
trash if this is a minute eyes in a
little bit with a religious answer white
privilege is a stand-in for original sin
it's a stand-in for our natural
religious understanding that we're
broken that we're falling something's
not right there's injustice in the world
the trouble with white privilege though
is it allows people it allows some
people to feel the goodness of like
whipping yourself and feel the goodness
of atoning for your sins and it allows
other people just to hate you just to be
like yeah you're the problem not me
I have no problems so it actually is
kind of exacerbates the worst parts of
both of this because it makes some
people aware of their imperfection but
with nothing to do about it and it makes
it actually leaves other people ignorant
of their own imperfections and breeds
hatred and division in the country it's
just a dumb idea it's a terrible idea
and we shouldn't give any quarter to it
you know that there is a squishy
response to this whole BLM peaceful
rioters kind of thing which is you saw
it from Jim mattis actually the former
defense secretary you saw it from George
W Bush a little bit which is to say hey
look these guys they have a point BLM
has a point the rioters they have a
point you know it's real they're
expressing pain and the way they express
pain is by stealing Nikes and Gucci bags
no they don't have a point they don't
it's a lie it is based on a lie we went
through
the numbers yesterday went through them
a little bit again today it is not true
they have no point whatsoever the things
that they're doing based on their lie
are terrible they're indefensible their
sins they are crimes the people who are
committing those crimes should be
arrested and thrown in prison for a very
long time some people insist that we
have to pretend like they have a point
in the spirit of national unity wrong
sorry buster actually if you pretend
they have a point you are you were
achieving precisely the opposite of
national unity you are encouraging
discord you were couraging strife you're
encouraging violence for nothing for a
lie for a ranked lie don't do it much
much better to take a clean and truthful
approach from Sarah my name is Sarah I
know that Sarah because I saw your name
is Sarah and I live in Madison Wisconsin
we have had riots the last few nights
like much of the country has there was a
press conference today that some of the
protest organizers held where they had a
list of demands that needed to be met in
order to stop the violence these demands
included defunding the police department
freeing all the inmates in the county
jail and abolishing police powers oh is
that all my question is how are we
supposed to respond to people like this
as citizens and what should our
government do in response you should
ignore those people you should ignore
those very unserious ideas
those are unserious ideas presumably put
forward by unserious people nobody
should take them seriously and for the
people who are committing the crimes
associated with this thing we should put
them in jail for a long time you know
there's been a big debate over prison
reform I'm actually supportive of prison
reform I think we need to toughen up our
sentences and put more people in prison
and here's my evidence for it the
country is burning to the ground so that
would seem to me indisputable evidence
that we don't have enough people in
prison because you know if we had those
criminals in prison then the country
wouldn't be burning to the ground
innocent people wouldn't be dying at
these peaceful protests peaceful
protests so you shouldn't take it
seriously unfortunately mayor's will
Garcetti is doing it in LA he's
defunding the police defunding the
police is going to make this situation a
lot worse actually just
not defending the police which so many
left-wing politicians are doing is
making the situation worse you're
looking at these riots and in a lot of
places the cops are just standing down
why are they standing down because they
know if they use any force at all which
is the definition of their job is to use
force right to maintain the order but if
they use force to maintain order they're
going to be maligned there's awful
terrible bigots and they're going to go
to jail probably so why would they do it
if they're not going to get any backup
from the elected officials from the
civil authority why on earth would they
do it and so the fires raged whether
they have the money or not
it's it's a terrible proposal and a nun
serious one but in a way in many places
it's probably inevitable from Nick can
we make Trump the Pope after his fourth
term as president I'm just thinking out
loud here just saying it would be
awesome yes
Donalda s' Maximus didn't Aldous the
first I like the sound of that end
president Trump's wife I believe is
Catholic which is that would be a mark
in his favor the marking against him
would be that he has a wife that does
complicate things if you're a pope
though you know some Pope's in the past
they've they've had wives a little a
little less publicly you know then then
President Trump so you know look I'm I'm
eager to see how the Conclave deals with
it because I think he'd be a great
candidate from Elizabeth dear Michael I
like the rest of the country watched
with sorrow anger amazement and awe the
destruction caused around the country
this weekend many disavow this behavior
but one way I've seen people defending
this online is through memes and posts
depicting Jesus overturning the tables
in the temple I believe this is a
misrepresentation of the gospel and I
would wager that many invoking the scene
are not devout followers yeah you think
but are looking for a way to discredit
Christians online who may say that these
actions are unacceptable I'm a devout
Catholic I've always seen this
particular story is an example of
Jesus's personhood I can't accept that
this interpretation is correct and it's
being used to justify this current
behavior would love to hear your
thoughts
this stupid meme I've seen this meme too
it's so dumb it's this meme it's a
picture of Jesus overturning the temples
and casting out the money changers and
and it says conservatives hate political
violence
Jesus says right and then it's this
image they're missing a few parts of the
story first one
you are not Jesus it should be the most
obvious but fairly it's not the second
one the money changers belong to Jesus
because Jesus is their creator because
Jesus is God and then the third one
Jesus is not going into somebody else's
house into these money changers house
and throwing them out right and stealing
their property and going he is throwing
them out of his own father's house
actually in the in the verse says right
they are in my father's house so nothing
about the meme is correct whatsoever but
this is this is you know the typical
online leftist atheist kind of thing
will say hey you Christian idiot if God
is real then why do bad things happen to
good people
mic drop checkmate Christian showed you
there goes your religion like mmm you
know there's some books about this
there's some people have thought about
this before and this is this falls
squarely in that category from David to
Noel's knower of much smoker of quality
cigars on the Catholic and as the Pope
is supposed to be the person I follow in
my religious life I do find myself at
odds with his political views yeah his
criticism of Trump standing in front of
st. John's with the Bible being the most
recent time he's spoken up against our
president any thoughts yeah it's it's
funny that you bring this up because you
know I'm obedient to my bishops and of
course to the Bishop of Rome who is the
Pope cuz I'm a Catholic too
I don't even know what he said about
Trump in the Bible I don't I didn't even
read it like I heard there was a thing
that he said but okay Pope's say a lot
of things there is a big
misunderstanding here many people
especially non Catholics or even many
Catholics believe that that papal
infallibility this is this idea that the
Pope is always correct whatever he says
and we have to believe every single
thing the Pope says not true
that is certainly
the case when the Pope is talking about
political matters or economic matters he
might be wrong 99% of the time he might
frankly he could be wrong 100% of the
time even as long as he is not speaking
from the chair from his official office
he can be perfectly fallible you know
the the idea of sometimes we've had
Pope's who have just gotten political
questions wrong that might be a way for
the good Lord to tell us that the Pope
is fallible except when he is infallible
which by the way the Pope is speaking in
fallows spoken infallible I think twice
in all of history the rest of the time
can be fallible you know move on
somebody says something you don't like
just move on from Shannon dear host with
the most ease a mite the host okay I am
the host with the most ease at the Daily
wire well learned something new every
day
now Jeremy boring Michael yeah that's
Jeremy boring sorry is perpetuating the
white Savior industrial complex the
answer it's a good way to put it if not
what color should I put post on
Instagram to show my support saw this
with Lincoln it's a quirk of liberalism
and paganism is actually the real answer
here this idea of the white Savior being
a bad thing so Lincoln frees the slaves
right when the movie Lincoln came out
the Lincoln movie showed the story was a
beautiful movie Daniel day-lewis plate
Lincoln there was a push back on the
left because they said hold on you're
suggesting Lincoln freed the slaves but
we're not relying on some white guy to
free the slaves the slaves freed
themselves but that isn't true Lincoln
freed the slaves the Union Army freed
the slaves 700,000 Americans died to
free the slaves
but this doesn't jibe with liberalism
this doesn't jibe with some forms of
paganism because we want to do
everything ourselves liberalism is just
all about it liberalism on the left and
the right it's me I have to do it I have
to have agency everything in life is
about my will and the things that I
achieve same thing with paganism when
you read the ancient pagan epics it's
all about my heroic actions my own
heroic nobility this is different than
Christianity Christianity
accepts grace right we say like I
actually don't need to earn my own
salvation I can't earn my own salvation
my salvation is given to me as a gift by
someone else and that's a wonderful
thing and I'm happy about that
that that civilization of grace is what
defined our own the West until about
five minutes ago until now we're in this
kind of post Christian political moment
or secular political moment but that's a
much better situation and and when it
comes to these historical questions and
most notably on slavery then it's it's
obviously the correct one as well all
right that's our show we got more to get
to but you know I gotta wait until
Monday
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
and Michael Nolt show see them
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20/20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there